on on va commencer par par Carl olive et
et ce superbe livre Les Carnets secret
de Michel hiidalgo hein qui qui est
sorti il y a il y a quelques jours euh
Carl expliquez-nous un petit peu bah
comment est venu ce ce projet de de
récolter et de relater ces kilos de de
de causerie de du sélectionneur d'abord
je suis très heureux de d'être avec vous
sur sur le plateau de TVfil je crois
pouvoir dire que Michel Idalgo est un
homme vrai celui qui met ses actes en
face de ses mots euh en 1978 il est
arrivé à la tête de cette équipe de
France en Argentine et il a réussi à
voilà un petit peu créer la surprise
contre l'Italie ensuite contre
l'Argentine et puis en 1982 ben il y a
eu effectivement ce ce France Allemagne
on peut-être parler et puis je crois que
michelidalgo il a tout simplement créé
le socle un petit peu de notre Coupe du
monde
1998 avec des valeurs jeanubiman à côté
de moi et on sait ce que représente les
les valeurs dans dans le monde de
l'Ovalie mais effectivement il a il y a
des valeurs et il y avait la tête et les
jambes et pas seulement et pas seulement
les jambes à l'époque vous parlez de
valeurs ces valeurs c'est c'est un peu
la responsabilisation des joueurs c'est
ce qu'on ce qu'on peut lire dans dans le
livre cette autogestion presque qui
serait quasiment impossible aujourd'hui
avec la génération actuelle oh je crois
que tout est possible d'ailleurs Didier
Deschamp pour pas le nommer a commencé à
mettre en place un petit peu de de de
faux semblant comme Michel dalgo aimait
à les mettre en place au début des
années 80 19 1982 pour ceux qui se
souviennent de de cette compétition je
dira que c'est presque l'été indien pour
le football on découvre la Côte d'Amour
des footballeur français avec un pays il
y a une diette depuis 1958 et la Coupe
du monde en Suède il y avait pas eu
vraiment de coupe du monde de héros
français c'est arrivé en G fone
exactement fontaine et Copin c'est
arrivé en 1982 et puis Michel dalalgo à
l'époque préparait avec minuci toutes
ses causeries il se trouve que j'ai eu
la chance de rencontrer Michel dalalgo
pour un premier ouvrage en en 1984 et
puis ensuite en en 2000 en 2004 et j'ai
proposé à Michel de ressortir ces
causeries et de façon banale m'a dit bah
viens viens dans mon Grenet j'en ai
quelques quelques pages il en avait 5 kg
voilà donc il y a pas 5 kg de caerie
dans dans l'ouvrage mais enf enfin voilà
c'est une approche un petit peu un petit
peu différente et surtout elle je dirais
qu'elle est très moderne 30 ans après et
on voit des images qui font pas
forcément plaisir à tous les amourux de
football on en parlera de ces images on
les verra encore tout à l'heure votre
amour du football a débuté quand c'était
82 ça commencait avant écoutez moi je je
suis ici une famille nombreuse on était
les huit frères et sœurs ont joué au
football les tous les frères ont voulu
être footballeur professionnel il y en a
qu'un qui réussi c'est ma sœur voilà qui
est internationale et voilà donc quand
vous êtes h dans une famille on on tape
dans le ballon dès le plus jeune âge et
comme je disais Anthony en préparant
l'émission je crois pouvoir dire que
1982 je suis capable de vous donner les
les compositions d'équipe de vous donner
tous les matchs parce que à l'époque
c'est 13 ans et puis ça voilà ça imprime
quelque chose les années 80 voilà c'est
c'est le disco c'est c'est la boom c'est
voilà toutes ces tous ces momentsl bah
pour les footballeurs c'est la Coupe du
Monde 1982 c'est le match France
Hollande avec le coup Fran Michel
Platini en novembre 81 et puis c'est la
reprise de volet de de Marius Trésor qui
nous fait l'amabilité de faire la
préface de ce bouquin incollable sur le
football on aura dû préparer un CA
exactement et au-delà de bah de ces de
ces carnets secrets de ces de ces
causeries qu'on que vous relatez il y a
aussi des portrait de joueurs les les
joueurs clés de de cette compétition
cette Coupe du Monde espagnole comme
dinoosof le le le plus vieux champion du
monde Rossy l'italien rubes l'allemand
le fameux attaquant allemand qui qui
marquait plus de 50 % de ses buts de la
tête et ça aussi c'est ça rend encore
l'ouvrage un peu plus riche hein mais
oui pourquoi Antony parce que des jeunes
comme vous voilà qui étiez pas né en
1982 c'est moi j'étais né hein mais bon
vous étiez pas très vieux al pas très
vieux mais j'ai quelques souvenir quand
même de la période oui c'est c'est
important de recamper le décor parce que
1982 on est dans une période
post-franquiste et on va s'apercevoir
que il y a y a il y a vraiment de de un
côté très rigoureux dans la compétition
l'organisation de cette compétition en
Espagne faut savoir qu'à cette époque-là
il y a des prisons au sein même des
structures et j'en veux pour preuve que
le match contre nos amis koétiens France
coè l'après-midi même il y a un
supporteur français qui a été emprisonné
et c'est Michel Idalgo soi-même qui est
allé entre guillemets le le délivrer on
est dans une période très rugueuse post-
franquiste et puis derailleurs on est
encore dans une période où je dirais il
y a la liberté de mouvement il y a la
liberté de de jouer les protèges tibias
sont pas obligatoires quand on dit ça
aujourd'hui ça paraît totalement
surprenant c'est pas obligatoire les Ch
était retroussé à cette époque voilà
exactement et puis vous verrez dans le
dans le DVD qui est àollé à au au
bouquin que il y a voilà il y a des
shorts qui sont vintage qui sont très
moulants ça appel remoiselle euh voilà
c'est des c'est des choses un petit peu
particulières j'en ai encore plein
d'émotions parce que raconté par Michel
Idalgo c'est vraiment un grand monsieur
du football avec des des des valeurs
avec un grand V quand vous vous
remémorez tous ces momentsl quand vous
discutez avec Michel Idalgo aussi vous
avez un regret de de voir que
aujourd'hui bah c'est pas forcément les
mêmes valeurs qui prédominent j'ai un
regret c'est qu' 31 contre l'Allemagne
en 1982 on est en finale et qu'à
l'arrivée on joue la finale de la 3e
place non le regret aujourd'hui c'est je
crois de de de pas mettre en place un
socle de valeur je le dis au moment où
Didier Deschamps la première conférence
de presse nouveau sélectionné l'équipe
de France en à l'été dernier a dit moi
ce qui m'intéresse voilà c'est les
valeurs je peux avoir un très bon joueur
si vraiment il il n'a pas les valeurs
qu'on qu'on qu'on met en place dans le
groupe France alors il sera mis de côté
voilà ça je trouve que c'est un bon
point et ça nous rappelle un petit peu
ce que faisait Michel Idalgo je pense
que Laurent Blanc s'est fait tuer par
des joueurs qu'il avait lui-même imposé
en équipe de France parce qu'il y avait
pas de respect et puis tout simplement
parce que les règles comme on on en
parle souvent dans rugby les règles
n'ont pas été mises en place avant le
début de la compétition avant la saison
avant la vie d'un groupe vous êtes dans
le jeu où vous êtes hors du jeu et
jusqu'à présent malheureusement après je
dirais 1998 c'est on s'aperçoit qu' il
faut un sélectionneur qui soit vraiment
un patron et aussi un homme ben il y a
pas eu ces règles qui ont été mis en
face des décisions qui étaient prises
vous êtes pas venu là ce soir juste à ce
titre là en tant que conseiller général
mais vous êtes conseiller général est-ce
que les politiques ont une
responsabilité aussi sur ça est-ce
qu'ils peuvent faire changer les choses
et impulser impulsé on a aussi vu des
des ministres he prendre position
pendant les dernières coupes du monde
sur certaines attitudes de jou bien sûr
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont une responsabilité
bien évidemment parce que le le football
professionnel commence ici commence ici
au au bord des terrains à 5 ans en
Yveline commence là à poissie où je suis
avec tout simplement de la part des
acteurs locaux de la part des dirigeants
de la part des éducateurs des règles de
vie le sport c'est l'école de la vie le
football c'est l'école de la vie c'est
le sport le plus populaire en France
surtout qu'il reste populaire et qu'on
continue à le montrer dans les journaux
à la télévision comme vous le faites si
bien ici à TVfil dans des moments où on
voit des gamins en action et arrêtons
d'occuper la place des faits divers et
comme le dit Michel Idalgo à me donné
dans une dans une causerie he être
sélectionneur être entraîneur c'est
faire des choix et donc exclure au final
et chose que peut-être les
sélectionneurs récents peut-être pas
c'est peut-être pas le cas de Didi
Deschamps mais ne ne ne le faisaent plus
assez en tout cas michelidalg aussi
Anthony prête à à didro cette belle
formule et je crois qu'elle est
importante le dialogue est la manière la
plus instructive de la la vie bah sans
dialogue on peut pas faire grand-chose
c'est comme au foot hein quand on fait
pas de face vaut mieux faire du Jok
carry et on peut pas évoquer évidemment
cette Coupe du Monde 82 vous vous vous
en parliez tout à l'heure sans ce fameux
match franceç franceç RFA puisque
c'était c'était la RFA à l'époque cette
demifinale perdu digne des des plus
grandes grandes pièces de théâtre qu'on
puisse imaginer on mène on mène 31 les
Bleus mènent 31 et puis on se fait
remonter et puis derrière cette
élimination et puis ce ce match pour la
4e place qui qui n'a plus de saveur au
final Michel Platini dit que sa plus
belle victoire de de de sa carrière
c'est la défaite contre la RFA en 1982
je crois qu'il a raison il y a eu un
avant RFA un après RFA je pense que
l'équipe de France a une côte d'amour
exceptionnelle phénoménale euh après ce
match-l et c'est vrai que à la 1008e
minute on menait encore 3 bu1 et qu'on
était en finale c'est Marius Trésor qui
dit cela c'est le le moment le plus
heureux de sa carrière et ce match c'est
le jour le plus triste de sa vie jusqu'à
ce moment-là voilà exactement c'est
cette fameuse action du du gardien
chumarur hein voilà dirait presque une
action de
rugby les causeries vous vous les
conservez Philippe vous en tant
qu'entraîneur je conserve un certain
nombre de de cahiers avec les notes qui
sont prises après chaque chaque
rencontre et je m'y réfère de temps en
temps ça peut être utile c'est vrai mais
j'en ai pas 5
kg c'est la grande exception de de
Michel Idalgo merci beaucoup Carl
d'êtreevenenu sur le plateau et puis
très beau livre à lire les carnets
secrets de Michel Idalgo avec é toute la
journée voilà il y a des des anecdotes
géniales et puis et beaucoup beaucoup de
beaucoup de secrets du vestiaire merci
beaucoup car de votre venue merci on va
passer au Trophée des champions qui qui
s'est déroulé cette tradational soirée
qui s'est déroulé mercredi dernier à
Versailles qui qui mettait à l'honneur
tous les tous les athlètes yvl noir qui
ont brillé pendant pendant cette saison
2012 c'était aussi l'occasion pour les
sportifs de se retrouver et et de se
lancer vers d'autres défis comme comme
les gios de Rio en 2016 un sujet réalisé
avec elodim moan
alerte à la concentration de champions
au mètre carré mercredi soir dernier à
Versailles sport scolaire et fédéral les
athlètes du département ont glané 68
titres nationaux cette saison et
11vinois ont participé aux Jeux
Olympiques cette soirée des champions
c'était aussi l'occasion de saluer
l'investissement du département qui doit
surtout continuer ou s'améliorer au
profit des jeunes espoirs je sais que
dans leses il y a beaucoup de sportif et
des sportifs qui qui pourratre de
meilleur niveau s'ils étai mieux
accompagnés donc la petit clin d'œil les
subventions sont toujours les bienvenus
parce que parce qu'il y a vraiment de
quoi faire dans les ivelines ce sont ces
jeunes athlètes qui doivent prendre la
relève à l'horizon des Jeux Olympiques à
Rio en 2016 comme les scriamers
trapistes Cédric enken champion de
France junior au fleuret où Léonie perio
championne du monde junior de triathlon
en attendant avec cette cérémonie le
chapitre Gio 2012 est définitivement
clos on commence à réaliser
effectivement qu'on a réalisé l'un de
ses plus gros objectifs euh un rêve même
quasiment on va dire parce que je
pensais vraiment pas aller au jeu de
2012 j'avais l'objectif d'aller au jeu
en 2016 donc j'ai pris un peu d'avance
sur l'objectif donc ben on en profite
pour se refixer des objectifs un peu
plus haut et viser 2016 avec cette
fois-ci une belle performance là-bas les
joueurs du parissgermain Christophe jaly
et Néné ont remis les trophées aux
athlètes une soirée qui a dû leur
changer les idées après l'élimination la
veille en Coupe de la Ligue par